hey guys this is dennis the founder
think here and i'm david griffin your
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the walking
dead season 4 episode was his 9 i'm so
nine is simply titled after it's the the
mid-season premiere yep after the long
break yes its back its back and record
numbers you were telling record numbers
be it even beat the olympics it beat
everything on television that night is
this thing this keeps growing can't stop
huge you can't stop it i have to say i
like half of it half of the episode yeah
can you guess which half of the episode
i liked i'm gonna guess I hope the
Michonne part yes ok good that's 32 I
enjoyed them as shown part very much I
like that I guess we can't call him
flashbacks it's more dream like sequins
re my flashback yeah yeah to mention i
liked it i we got to see some Michelle's
back story of how she used to be and how
she had a family and a husband and a kid
and all these things and how they've
kind of messed her up yeah in today's
world right and I liked your just I seen
her I mean to see her kind of breakdown
because uh you know I was like to tie in
some of the comic books so you know we
have a volume 9 here we remain volume 9
if you start reading this it's almost
except for some different characters are
dead something cooked or alive won't
spoil who that is but it's almost pays
for page for the first few pages the
exact same sequence that you see
Michonne in here walking through the the
prison you know the yard and stabbing
somebody's head a different head notnot
Herschel's but somebody else's and but
now we actually at the back story
because otherwise before Rick and Carl
meet back up with her you don't really
get what she's going through what's
inside of her head would open and also
we don't know where you know a lot of
her anger and we actually get to see her
breakdown and this one we gonna see
where her anger and frustration so stoic
from even the comic book she's strolling
all the time and it's no surprise that
it's it's it's just like conflict
because a Robert Kirkman you have this
episode we have Greg Nicotero directly
hmm so yeah I really like the Michonne
parts and I'm glad you know at the end
she comes back and right is going to
reconnect with Rick and Carl and the
guess that's true I guess we can
transition anybody go back a little bit
later but transition into Carl and Rick
which I thought was the weaker have that
half that we cannot like and I hate to
say it because you know some of you I'm
sure out there like Dennis and I you
know I know you didn't read past this
you'd best I issue 48 at the end of the
prison is without reading The Walking
Dead so for those of you read past this
like if you if you've read this like it
is pretty much page for page what
happens for a lot of a lot of the parts
like all the stuff that Carl goes to in
the house he's running around his
finding some you know his dad being sick
all that stuff happens a problem is this
isn't the show's fault it's not the
actors fault the kids too old like if
you look at Carl in this picture he's a
little kid the Hat like just covers his
whole body like he's really little I'm
always even 10 years old ten-year-old
kid but because Carl was like this kind
of bratty and dying I don't know how is
he 14 15 year-old kid I just don't I
don't care if he lives or dies I don't
feel any compassionate for him but
here's a 10 year old I really do fear
for his life I mean I don't think he can
survive on his own but because we've
already seen him fire off automatic
rifles in the prison he's killed people
he shot his own ma or whatever I mean
it's just like you don't I don't I don't
know I don't feel that same fear as i
did in the book for now hey at least for
the show version i hope a zombie eat oh
yeah i don't care for him he's he's
really bright I know he's gone through a
lot and people always say well he's gone
through all this stuff and blow up one
okay well I got to two things about that
one first of all just in this episode
you see his father rick is physically
injured and hurt he's like really
sobbing his face is all messed up once
you chill out there right you know I
don't care whatever kind of stuff that
you got going on right it's your one of
your parents right like who barely he
looks like he's about to fall over and
die yeah and Carlos says no I mean he's
being a dick from the very beginning you
know I don't I just I miss it I know I
should I'm really not a prude when it
comes to you know the book to television
and movie habitations I love Lord of the
Rings read the books of the Rings I love
Harry Potter but all the books love the
movies equally but with this so it
really aged really starting to bother me
because the car liking this he's crying
psych i miss my mom he's still a little
kid he's not be
bratty and a dick to his dad all the
time I mean and when he you know
survives all the zombies attacking him
in the book you really feel this intense
connection to him because he's such a
little kid you like man he survives like
that I killed all these zombies on my
own Sokka but we've already seen Carl
kill a lot of zombies he's has a machine
gun just going you know do do do do do
it like earlier so it's like I just
don't feel the same connection with this
version of Carl as I do from the books
and I know it's not the actors fault the
kids got it hit puberty it's gonna
happen saan his fault but well I've been
read past the prison storyline in the
comic book so for me it's just I'm
judging it based on what this story has
been it's always been this on and off
again of I hate my dad and then oh my
dad's okay I hate my dad and my dad's
okay you know and and so with this
episode I was just like dude just shut
up yeah yes shut up like get over
yourself man I'm yeah I think I oh I
forgot the second part the second yeah I
talked about the is the fiscal number
two okay some people have been in
telling me Dennis it's you know he's
that age and you know all the kids were
annoying that ages like I'm like sure
okay I wasn't that annoying but yes I
could I can say okay but we're talking
about people living in today's world
where everything's cool everything's
nice yeah for the most part at least you
know in it you know where we live sure
um this is the post-apocalyptic zombie
world it's not like his dad is an
alcoholic it's not like his dad is a
drug user it's not like his diet is a
criminal that's better person he's not
abusive he you know he's not cheating on
his wife you know or like a lot of
things that cause a lot of angst and
anger amongst teenagers right they have
zombies chasing them trying to kill them
there's more important things going on
than what he's you know and I feel like
even at that kind of tumultuous age but
that you could get that you know that
that's something like that is much
bigger than whatever and what is he
blaming his dad for yeah i mean he's
blaming them for you know the death of i
mean there there is a scene in here so
they do take it out of the book
of him yelling at his dad you know
saying you know I mean granted he's
yelling different names because people
have died and not died here but like you
couldn't protect this person this person
but because he's a little kid and he's
crying as he's yelling he'd know he's
just he's scared like he admits he's
like I'm just like there's a part here
he says like I'm scared I admit that I'm
just scared I'm i need you you know and
it's just where where is that in the
teenage they don't go after that yeah he
just comes off as being a little bratty
and I don't he doesn't come off as being
being bratty in here I don't like him
being bratty it just it just bothers me
i don't i just can't connect with Carl
I'm sorry like I I just can't connect
with them but Michonne that part of the
story did like I'll give credit I did
like the scene to give credit to the
Takara I did like the scene where he
looked at the video games and he looked
at you know the the movies and the TV
and in the room and he had this like
moment of like oh what a play some xbox
and then he's like oh wait let me take
the hdmi cable and you know the guy i
don't know why some thought the asian my
cable would hold the door yeah i don't
care what kind of not that you hdmi
cable yeah i usually my cables gonna
hold the door for a bunch of zombies
right i mean the Rick with smart for
pushing the couch move the guy Nevel
extra reinforcement yeah those zombies
are rough and essentially the zombies
are never quite the same some are
stronger than the other one with that
one he was fighting in the room it took
his shoe yeah people were making fun of
Karl I saw some comments on Twitter and
other entertainment sites that Carl's
tough to fight off all those zombies but
it couldn't get a shoe back he's a kid I
gotta give him credit he's a little kid
so yeah I do think this one part though
was kind of cheesy the whole Rick
they're trying to make Rick like a
zombie like so that Carl was like number
one is the audience we know he's not a
zombie and number two there's no reason
why Rick would do that why would Rick
after work you know waking up going go
oh it's all dark and shadowy oh and act
like a zombie only if you wanted to play
that that way yeah to think that you can
I don't know if your trick trying to
trick the audience because no one's
fooled right or you know for Carl to be
you know
no did I think it was a mistake to do
that scene yeah it's it's a tough
balance because they did I mean Kirkman
did pull a lot of this you know from the
comic he really did stay close and true
it's just it's just really hard for me
that I said this before hard to be
connected with call and I wish I could I
am trying to be open-minded I'm not you
know and I think it really against the
actor it's just the way they it's like
Andrea yeah you know I mean I think if
the show has done some things better
it's um I love the governor way Moi's
way more fleshed out much more of a
character you can kind of you know I
guess at least understand however was
better Shane was backing was much better
more in depth yeah so don't like we're
attacking the show on a whole it's just
some characters Carl I think they've
done a poor job of doing within an
Andrea they they did such a bad job with
her they had to kill her off and for
those of us that have read the comics
are still reading the comics the
injuries like when the best characters
he's won my fear I love and then you
have someone that like Daryl which is
the best in my opinion the best
character on the show yeah that wasn't
in the comic yeah and he's great yeah so
so next week we get yes they're all
Glenn Maggie those other characters that
I care about the most yeah I'm more I'm
excited about nexus oh yeah next week we
got to see what's going on with them for
sure so you know with this episode you
know I like some of it in a Shone's part
didn't really care for Carl's part but
the next episode i think i'll be a much
happier way right all right all right
guys so that's why you thought of this
episode of the walking dead you can post
your comments below on the website think
hero.com or on our youtube channel think
aeropro make sure to subscribe to that
you can also come chat with us on
twitter you know please let us know what
you're thinking or is anybody reading
the comic books have you read the comic
books if you give him a try do you like
him better I like him better are you
playing The Walking Dead the tell-tale
video game I did a review that about a
month ago it's one of my favorite video
games out right now so check that out
you can check with Dennis and I think
hero personally i'm at griffin de and we
asked on facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans make
sure you to like that page and you know
share our videos on Twitter and Facebook
and all that stuff